[موسيقى]
عطلت العاصمه السعوديه الرياض متصدره
للمشهد الفني عالميا في حفل اسطوري جوائز
20 23
[موسيقى]
شكرا
قالها مع المستشار تركي ال الشيخ فوق
الخيال فاحنا قاعدين نعيش فوق الخيال هذا
الاحتفاليه دائما اقول اي احتفاليه هذه
تمت زراعه شجره لتصبح مظله الفن لتصبح
مركز الفن بنقول العالم انه مركز الفن
القادم من يوم ورايح هو المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
الموسم الثالث من وورد اضافه جائزه جديده
تحت اسم صناع الترفيه الماسيه تم تقديمها
لرئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه ام بي سي الشيخ
وليد الابراهيم
اللي تشوفونه الان في الرياض هو البدايه
بدايه بسيطه جدا العمل مهما كان القياده
مكه واعطه واذا ما في رجال ينفذون على
الارض مثل الرجال هذا اللي قاعد قدامنا
فعالي مستشار تركي ال الشيخ
ومثله رجال اخرين اليوم موجودين عملوا عمل
المستحيل وجبار كما تم تكريم فنانين من
حول العالم بجوائز فخريه خاصه لصناعه
ترفيه وجوائز الانجاز مدى الحياه وشخصيه
العام وكان للراحلين نصيب من الحضور في
الحفل رغم غيابهم
[موسيقى]
حصد فيلم كيرا والجن على جائزه الفيلم
المفضل يعني مين هيكسب الجائزه يعني
الافلام كلها حلوه يعني وجودنا هنا هو ده
الحاجه الكويسه يعني اهم حاجه ان احنا
الاثنين معنا مفتاح البيت
يعني مش هيكسب معه مفتاح
الافضل والممثل الافضل سينمائيا للفنانه
هند صبري والفنان احمد عز
بما حقيقه اغنيه شكرا للفنانه اصاله لقب
الاغنيه المفضله كلنا عم نتنافس لحب الناس
يعني هذه اهم شيء وبالنهايه اذا عم نتنافس
بتكون منافسه شريفه لنقدم الافضل للناس
دائما وحققت المطربه انغام لقب الفنانه
المفضله ولقب الفنان المفضل ذهب للمطرب
عبد المجيد عبد الله
لكن الاعمال
موسيقيا كان من نصيب الفنانه جوري قطان
حسنك هتاخذي الجائزه ولا تروح عليك
انت ايش تقول انا لو قلت هتخرب الدنيا
ان شاء الله في منال لتعبير الصغير جائزه
المؤثره المفضله وجائزه المؤثر المفضل
ذهبت لاحمد الشقيري
[موسيقى]
وخطف النجم اشرف حكيمي جائزه الرياضيه
المفضله وجائزه الرياضيه المفضله خطفتها
مريم صالح بن نادر
شكرا جزيلا انا سعيد بتواجدي في هذا البلد
ليله خاصه نستمتع فيها انا وعائلتي شكرا
لدعمكم
مسلسل صالون زهره على جائزه المسلسل
[موسيقى]
قول والله كمان والله ليش انت بتعرف يعني
احساس
بلا سالتك
وجائزه الوجه الجديد المفضل دراميه كانت
من نصيب الفنانه هيلدا ياسين
المئات من المعي نجوم الفن والرياضه
عالميا توافدوا للعاصمه السعوديه للسير
على السجاده البنفسجيه في واحده من ابرز
ليالي موسم الرياض
[موسيقى]